Our next course is a halibut
from Maine
lovingly glazed in
an orange-cranberry mostarda.
I have an awkward question
for you, Lillian.
Is that halibut
actually from Maine?
Your butler, Poopers, just said
it, but I assume he was japing.
Poopers, is that halibut
from Maine?
I can almost smell the bearded
fisherman who caught it.
Get rid of that poison!
Garfield,
remove this atrocity at once!
I apologize
one thousand-fold.
You're quite handsome
when you throw out food
a dog has spit out.
Oh, thank you, Chair.
Do you ever wonder
what it would be like to taste
one tiny, little bite?
I know I do,
but I'm not as brave as you.
Maybe you could try it
and tell me what it's like.
No, I could never!
It's an unpardonable offense
to eat that which is designated
for the upstairs.
I must throw it
in the garbage.
I'd love to see
just one small morsel
in your perfect
little mouth.
[scoffs]
Well, I...
guess I could have
one little nibble.
Yes.
It's like
a flaky little cloud!
What did you say
this was called, again?
- Food.
- Well, if this is food,
then I'm glad
to have tried it.
It makes working for gruel
that much more rewarding,
knowing that real food is going
to its rightful place, upstairs.
Well, I surely enjoyed
watching you do it.
Well, then I am glad
to have danced with the fire.
[psychedelic music]